Hey everyone! It's Mark Wiens with migrationology.com in Singapore
Right now, I'm at the Tekka Centre which is a
wonderful food court hawker centre/shopping centre
of all things in Little India and it's one of the best places to come if you are looking for Indian food
This is a very popular market and food centre
just immediately right off the Little India MRT Station
And it's right in Little India in Singapore
On the bottom floor, is a big food centre
Which is a giant food court open air food court
and while there are some Chinese food dishes stalls available
The majority of the stalls at this hawker centre are all Indian
and there's some Malay as well, but really I think it really focuses on the Indian Stalls
So if you are looking for curry, if you are looking for prata, if you are looking for biryani rice
This is one of the ultimate places to come in Singapore
And then also on the other side, there is a fresh market where you can get all sorts of produce
and then there are also a lot of shopping stalls where you can buy clothes
This is kind of an all in one Indian shopping centre and food court in the heart of Singapore
One of the things that i had to order was roti prata
and this is a prata i got it with an egg and onions on the inside
He stretched out the dough and then added an egg and some onions into the middle
and then folded it into a little package and he fried it up fresh
I'm gonna eat this right now because it is hot and fresh
and served with a curry sauce
Oh yes! All of the aroma! Oh that's really hot, okay we just break into that
Oh you can, wow that's even hot to touch, you can smell that aroma the onions and the egg in there
Go for a quick dip in the curry sauce
Oh that's just awesomely good! The roti it is a little bit crispy on the edges, but most of the roti is just kind of sticky and doughy
and then the inside is filled with an egg as well as onions which are very fragrant and still a little bit crisp
and then yeah definitely taking it to the next level as that curry sauce
That's where a lot of flavor comes from and the curry sauce is not spicy, it's mild
But it really goes well together with that plain roti
This makes a great breakfast, because it's kind of an all in one little meal
And with your eggs inside there as well
That's just simple and good!
Another one of the stalls here at Tekka Centre that I was really looking forward to try was Allaudin's nasi biryani
and they specialize in dum biryani and when you walk up to the front there,
you can just smell the aroma of the spices, you can see the giant pots that they cook the rice and the chicken in
and so I ordered a plate and what he did was he really carefully dished out some rice onto the plate,
just a couple scoops at first and then after that he topped it with a piece of chicken,
and then after that he went back to the pot of rice and scooped on some more rice on top of that,
so the chicken is sort of sandwiched between two layers of rice,
and then after that I had it, I got an egg on the side,
and then he served it with a side bowl of curry sauce
And so this is the complete dish, the rice is very orange and yellow colorful long strands of basmati rice
There are onions in here, the aroma's fantastic! I also got it with an egg on the side,
and I'm just gonna try some of that rice first
Oh that rice has a beautiful fragrance to it,
I think I can taste some cardamom in there, maybe some cloves and definitely some cumin
The rice is a little bit of moist, it really depends on what type of biryani you have,
sometimes it's more dry, other times this one is a little more on the moist side
and also you can really taste those onions really fragrant onions in that rice as well,
is that a chicken leg I believe? I can't even Oh! Look at how tender that chicken just slipped off!
Oh look at that! And I better take a bite with just some of that sauce before I go into the curry sauce
That chicken is so soft and tender! Sometimes when a chicken is really really soft,
it tends to get mushy and sort of like starchy almost,
but somehow this chicken is ridiculouly soft, but it's not mushy at all,
and it's just brilliant! Wow!
And then with that curry sauce, and then with that spiced fragrant rice,
that is just simply a marvelous combination!
Add some of that curry sauce to the egg,
Oh yeah! It's a chunky curry sauce, there are curry leaves in here and there is potatoes in here as well
Those curry leaves are brilliant!
The curry sauce has a really nice fragrant from the curry leaves used in there,
and I believe that there's also eggplant in that curry sauce,
which has been cooked for so long that it started to dissolve into the curry sauce,
so it's almost kind of thickened by that eggplant
That was a great plate of nasi biryani! And I'm still amazed that how the chicken was so soft,
but the texture remains really good and not mushy
That was delicious! And really this entire Tekka Centre,
it's a wonderful wonderful place to come if you love Indian food,
I notice mostly South Indian food, but really a broad spectrum of different dishes to order,
lots of stalls and when you walk around you can just smell the aroma of those spices within the humidity of the air of Singapore
It's beautiful! I want to thank all of you who recommended the Tekka Centre to come for to eat,
this is a wonderful place and I appreciate you all recommending it
Please remember to give this video a thumbs up if you enjoyed it,
and also subscribe for more food videos, and I will see you on the next food video